what's the point of having a slow-ass
movie week if you can't use this
opportunity to review the prequels I go
into this knowing that I'm not going to
say everything I have to say I have a
lot to say about Star Wars Episode two
so just know if I didn't talk about it I
probably forgot
feel free to mention it below on that
note here we go
Star Wars Episode two attack of the
clone this is gonna be pretty spoiler
heavy so you've been warned
so deck of the clones takes place ten
years after the Phantom Menace right
there I always thought when I saw this
movie at first I was like why did you
need the Phantom Menace ultimately
Anakin's grown up now he's a new
character his relationship with Padme he
doesn't have it everyone's just kind of
in a different place ten years later so
why even have the Phantom Menace I would
have been finding this whole prequels
soccer just started out here it's like
ah Anakin he's an apprentice he's a Jedi
we can just hear at one point like oh
yeah when I found you on the farmer
right let's go do some and that'd
be that you don't need the Phantom
Menace so why have the Phantom Menace oh
yeah so we can have pod racing video
games I forgot so George Lucas describes
attack of the clones as ultimately a
love story so I suppose we should talk a
lot about that this is a love story
in here it makes zero sense and you
don't buy it whatsoever
yeah this attractive doing this
attractive chick and he says creepy
things to her you give some creepy ass
moments in there oh my god like that
saver he's like sorry milady Oh
tone it back there Stamos it don't come
on so heavy and ultimately someone Jango
Fett tries to kill Padme or rather Jango
Fett is commissioned to kill Padme so he
Commission's another bounty hunter to
kill Batman this is how you get the
galaxy to think you're a bad asses you
actually hire other people to do your
kills I remember I mean this droid opens
up the window and slips these little
worms in here it has this little tube
holding the worms but I'm like can you
just have salt like a grenade in there
open the window boom boom dead a blaster
a laser shooting m80 in her head have
you do that and you can't have the Jedi
go off their little adventure so in the
course of this Padme has to go back to
Naboo and Obi ones gonna investigate
these cloners so they send Anakin this
dude who looks like me obviously this
dude scores a lot of ass or he would if
he wasn't a Jedi they'd send him with
this really attractive girl alone to her
home and at that point you have the
cheesiest most force the love story
you've ever seen in your life you don't
buy this that dialogue he's like
you were in my very soul I've been
tormented by this mess Roby once sets up
but Master obi-wan and I are playing
hide the salami all I think about is you
and then she's like no we can't date but
she's wearing these really sexiest
outfits another series basically pouring
his heart out and really shitty terrible
love dialogue she's wearing this really
sexy black outfit I'm like
are you wearing that if you don't want
to date the dude are you wearing that to
fit in is that like normal nabu attire I
don't get it I don't get why Jed I can't
date for those of you who don't know
before Star Wars Episode two ever came
about this rule about Jedi not being
able to date or marry or have kids it
just was nowhere I don't remember it
anyway and I was a huge Star Wars fan
back then even Luke banged Mara Jade in
the books they're not canon anymore but
at the time they were can and I remember
seeing the teaser banner for this movie
it says something like a Jedi shall not
know anger nor hatred nor love I
remember scene that was like oh so
they're like Mormon missionaries pretty
much they pair up in pairs of two and
they can't chase chicks you just being
beaten over the head with this terrible
love dialogue you're like you're not
buying the romance you don't see it grow
through out there in the lily fields
you're like why are you in an open field
when the assassins trying to kill you
you see a sniper they're talking like
you're making fun and become bad Oh dad
but it's not romantic you don't feel
like they're growing closer together you
just it's wasting your time and then
obi-wan is out there like chasing Jango
Fett he comes across these cloners and
that's like this some interesting
happens in Kamino cuz they're like a
Jedi Master sifo-dyas whoever the hell
that is
commissioned the construction of a clone
army he was his Jedi Council member and
Obi Wan's like Master sifo-dyas was
killed almost 10 years ago it was like
oh wait a minute when you said almost 10
years ago I was thinking oh so he was on
the Jedi Council in the Phantom Menace
events all right let's comb through the
Jedi Council you know you're watching
the DVD trying to find this master
cypher did and then he gets on the horn
with Yoda and mace windu and he was like
Jedi Master sifo-dyas did this he said
it was commissioned almost 10 years ago
I was in under the impression he was
killed before that now he's been killed
before the Phantom Menace they're like
there's conflicting information there
this movie is full of conflicting
information I mean this may be
nitpicking but the Devils in the details
when it comes to movies it's the little
details that weave the world together
and make you feel like oh yeah it's like
a real world with the prequels there's
just no attention to detail even at the
point where Palpatine's whispering and
Anakin zere he's like I Fosse becoming
the greatest of all Jedi even more
powerful than Master Yoda then Anakin's
talking about obi-wan he was like
obi-wan I'm really glad to be his
apprentice he's as wise as Master Yoda
and as powerful as Master Windu at that
point shouldn't Palpatine be like even
more power for the mouse to Windu
another mixed signal is the fact that
Anakin's like possession is forbidden in
obi one holds his lightsaber to him he's
like this wet
is your life like all right well I
obviously possession is not forbidden
because I have to so cherish this
lightsaber as my life and the fact that
in the opening scroll it calls Count
Dooku the mysterious Count Dooku and you
find out he was once a Jedi so I'm
pretty sure the Jedi have all the
information on him and probably his
social security number if they use those
little bits of conflicting information
like that or throughout this movie Oh in
the end of cipher Deus thing doesn't
mean you get intrigued by X you
want to know who this is you it's gonna
be a mystery it doesn't matter the
prequels never tell you who the hell
that is so the only real interesting
plot point in this movie is now gone I'm
not even gonna fault Hayden Christensen
and Natalie Portman for having shitty
dialogue in this movie I don't think as
they're following George Lucas
ultimately drafted this out no one
checked it over because he's George
Lucas he's like not as perfect don't
even hear stories about you know that
whole action scene in the conveyor belt
George Lucas wrote it on the way to the
shoot and it shows it's like this out of
nowhere conveyer belt action sequence
the only thing missing is I thought they
were gonna fight jowenko the lava beast
at the end they didn't they probably
should have the worst line in the entire
movie the one where you're like this is
what I'm talking this is why I don't buy
it
this movie has to shove it in your faces
down your throat like they love each
other it's when Padme is like I love you
and Annika's like I thought we weren't
gonna love and she's like I truly deeply
love you like no one says that you
either love someone or you don't you
don't have to be like I truly deeply
love you the fact that it feels like
they're so desperately trying to prove
to you that they're in love just shows
you that they're not in love but I'm
going to point out some positives it's
the first time in the entire sagas
history that we saw a bunch of Jedi just
waiting to throw down you're like oh
this is gonna be awesome not gonna lie
I've wanted to see this all my life
now I'm going to when the Jedi start
fighting the droids granted I want a
Jedi to fight you know with lightsabers
and against other things with
lightsabers and you know like Old
Republic style but we take what we can
get so Jedi are throwing down but the
thing that makes me go uh there's no
conviction your artistic vision Lucas
with mace windu whips out his lightsaber
and it's purple and Lucas's reasons like
a samuel l.jackson wanted purple if I
were in the movie I would want a purple
lightsaber I would expect George Lucas
to be like no because there's a reason
lightsabers are the colors they are so
you don't get purple now that samuel
l.jackson has a purple lightsaber just
tells me there's no structure at all in
the color of the lightsaber look at a
blue one
he had a green one obi-wan had a blue
one why Gong Jin had a green one why it
doesn't matter when the cool Star Wars
II lightsaber is going down I mean
it's an entertaining enough in The Count
Dooku fight happens I think someone was
like hey George that fight with Darth
Maul that was a bit too choreographed a
bit too perfect pull it back a bit make
it a little more real so he tried to do
that and in the end it's just it's
boring you see Luke and Vader and they
were throwing down Vader could have just
kicked his ass but he was kind of toying
with him he's like ah you've learned
much young boy but there was reason
behind the fighting there was reason
behind the dialogue no lightsaber fight
was a byproduct of the point of the
moment this was a lightsaber battle
happen because I have to have a
lightsaber battle this is weird just
like the lights go out it's just them
going in front of their face and so like
stylistically go and fly it and it's
like that's weird like Lucas I
almost know what you were going for you
did not hit it and Yoda comes out and
does a lightsaber fight with Dooku I so
hate Yoda fighting with a lightsaber I
really do cuz a little pointy Yoda is
that he is why it's like William
Wallace's uncle is like learn to use
this then I'll teach you to use this yo
dislike or I'll just use this and it's
all I need hokey religions are better
than ancient weapons and a blaster at
your side that's what Yoda taught us now
he's like no but need a lightsaber too
and I hate it because you know he and
Duke who have their force battle and
then Duke is like it's obvious that this
contest cannot be decided by our
knowledge of the force but by our skill
with a lightsaber which just tells me
lightsaber is just better than the force
that's what he told me that's what the
movie is now validating see I really
wanted to see young Darth Vader the
genesis of what we would know is one of
the greatest villains in cinematic
history what we got was this onee brat
nothing about Anakin and these prequels
screams darth vader to me he ultimately
reminds me of dandy from American Horror
Story freak show he's a spoiled little
brat wants everything his way and he
pouts when he doesn't get it but if he
told me dandy was the genesis of Darth
Vader I'd be like no Anakin's more or
less on the path to being a serial
killer not being a controlling military
force to be reckoned with
even the title attack of the clones
baffles me why is it called that the
clones attack once in the movie yeah
sure but it's just one event in the
movies not the overall plot it's not the
overall reason for the movie you look at
Empire Strikes Back like the Empire
Strikes Back why because the Empire is
striking back the Empire Strikes Back is
not called the Battle of Hoth because
that battle was
one thing that happened in the movie was
just like the kloons attacking was one
thing to happen in the movie once I
heard Yoda say a line I was like that's
what the movie should have been called
Yoda said the Shroud of the dark side
has fallen so Star Wars Episode two
should have been called Star Wars
Episode two Shroud of the dark side
that's the overall point of the movie so
that's what it should have been called
attack of the clones is just a dumb
title guys in the end Star Wars Episode
two is completely disappointing I hate
it as part of the Star Wars saga there
were some things that they're
entertaining in the sense that they
happen in the Star Wars saga I like the
fact that I finally got to see all the
Jedi as a whole just throwing down on
Geonosis I never seen that before in
this saga this is the first time you're
like oh my god Jedi are badasses
surprising enough to me I'm not gonna
dog this movie up I thought I was
and I watched it and I'm like it has a
couple moments I like not a lot I will
say Star Wars Episode two attack of the
clones is a terrible movie and you're
not gonna remember it in t-minus one day
oh I'd still remember because it's
Star Wars I guess that's the downside
you're always going to remember all
right Star Wars Episode two attack of
the clones have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know I know there's
a lot I wanted to talk about that I
probably forgot to say and if you
remember comment below please and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more